today on the Matt Walsh show Infamous
male tick tocker Dylan Mulvaney had a
star-studded Extravaganza in New York
celebrating his day 365 of girlhood the
entire daily wire lineup made an
appearance during the show we'll play
the clip and talk about it Joe Biden
lashes out at those who want to protect
children from abuse calling us sinful
the President also uses an alleged
letter from a child to promote the
gender wage Gap myth Netflix quietly
cancels its kids show featuring a
non-binary bison and our daily
cancellation a conservative author is
ruthlessly mocked by the left for not
being able to define the word woke but
since when is the left in any position
to make fun of anyone else for not being
able to define a word we'll talk about
all that and much more today on Matt
Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
I'm sure you've all heard about the
Silicon Valley bank failure by now it
was the second largest bank failure in
history and seems to be signaling an
even bigger problem with our entire
banking system things are extremely
turbulent right now and the stock market
hates turbulence you need to diversify
at least some of your assets therefore
into precious metals gold is a tangible
asset with a reliable store value
because it's not tied to any one economy
or currency it can be a safe haven in
times of Crisis like right now for
example Birch gold makes it easy to roll
over your IRA or 401K into an IRA backed
by physical gold and silver right now if
you buy gold you can get a free safe to
store it in that's right on qualifying
purchases now through March 31st Birch
gold will ship a free safe directly to
your door if you want to find out more
about that you have text Walsh to 989898
to claim your free info kit on gold and
to claim eligibility for your free safe
as well with your retirement at stake
you want to be confident in the
financial service companies that you
work with including whoever you choose
to uh for purchasing physical precious
metals as well text Walls to 9 89898 and
protect your savings with gold today
this week a male performance artist
Dylan Mulvaney celebrated his day 365 of
Womanhood actually I need to correct
myself he calls it girlhood not
Womanhood because this grown adult man
is very specifically imitating an
adolescent girl uh it was day 365 of
girlhood then to be precise and I guess
I need to correct myself again because
it was actually day Zero of girlhood he
has experienced precisely zero days of
being a girl or a woman a year from now
he'll still be sitting at zero days
another year after that still zero days
a year after that zero days and when he
dies he will leave this earth a man with
zero days spent being anything other
than a man and when archaeologists dig
up his bones centuries from now they
will know that they are the bones of a
man they won't know the preferred
pronouns of the bones they won't know
anything about the bones except that
they belong to a human male
when everything else is forgotten about
Dylan Mulvaney and everything else will
be forgotten about Dylan Mulvaney the
only fact that will remain is the one
fact he wants us to forget
so with those caveats we turn to
mulaney's day 365 celebration at the
Rockefeller Center commemoration really
uh began a day before when Mulvaney
appeared on Drew Barrymore's talk show
and sat there with a pleased expression
on his face when Barrymore literally
knelt at his feet and paid tribute to
the trans deity he went from there to
the red carpet and an even more adoring
crowd his day 365 included celebrity
guests and big musical numbers he uh
pranced around on stage and he basked in
the Applause of an adoring crowd who had
all come out to congratulate him for
pretending to be a girl for the past
year a fawning article in Rolling Stone
tells us that Mulvaney spent a week
rehearsing his day 365 performance it
also tells us that he started developing
the concept
six months ago which means that Mulvaney
had only been quote unquote
transitioning into a quote-unquote girl
for six months when he decided that his
transition needed to be celebrated with
a star-studded Gala in New York
but not everyone who starred in the show
chose to be a part of it in fact um as
it turns out I made a cameo appearance
along with the entire rest of the daily
wire crew because every good show needs
a villain and that was our role to play
watch things are going really well like
I just had my first dance as a girl and
oh I can pay my bills and I'm building
up a following and I feel supported and
you know what I'm feeling lucky let's
Google my name
Dylan Mulvaney is intentionally
degrading women every time he does this
woman face Minstrel show routine he is
insulting and demeaning them and doing
it on purpose and he and profiting off
of it and he doesn't care if that is the
most attractive you will ever look then
I don't even want to imagine what you'll
look like when you're at your ugliest
documenting his creepy fetishized
version of what it means to be a girl
well Dylan Mulvaney has had some surgery
to make his face look more like Bruce
Jenner's Dylan Mulvaney has just given
the best proof yet
that transgenderism broadly or at very
least the type of transgenderism that he
suffers from
is a sexual fetish
I just want to stop it there just for a
second and say that this comment from
Michael Knowles is Way Beyond The Pale I
mean how could you accuse this man of
engaging in a sexual fetish is it
because he has recorded videos singing
about his penis bulge
formalize the Bulge we are normalizing
the Bulge women can have bulges and
that's okay we're not gonna stare at
their crotches while they're wearing
their little shopping shorts at the mall
thank you love you bye
okay well I guess that is pretty good
evidence that this is a sexual fetish on
second thought
um all right so let's go back to the the
video then
Dylan is not a woman Dylan is playing a
caricature of a woman that one can say
he is a woman and become one of the most
influential women in America in just six
months of wearing dresses and ironing
his hair the patriarchy always wins gang
and there is Dylan Mulvaney as Audrey
Hepburn the difference being that Audrey
Hepburn was an actual woman with a
vagina
I did I showed it what why would you
give them even a second of your big day
well these are the people I have to deal
with on a regular basis so I thought I
should include them in the evening but
that doesn't mean you have to listen to
them well I've always loved a little
constructive criticism maybe there's
nothing constructive about that and it's
not just criticism it's indoctrination
trans and non-binary people have been
around for thousands of years
we have to pause it there again because
of course that's total nonsense
everything in the video is nonsense but
uh this always deserves special mention
billions of human beings lived on this
planet for thousands of years
civilizations Rose and fell without
anyone inventing anything that even
vaguely resembled the modern notion of
trans and non-binary it didn't exist
anywhere at all until a group of weirdo
psychologists and sexologists in the mid
20th century made it all up
that's the actual history correctly told
[Applause]
tricks
I think we've established that I really
like to talk so I don't think they're
going to have the best luck silencing me
truthfully I don't know what their goal
is
but I do know how they make me feel now
that I've built up a thicker skin
it doesn't hurt me
do you want to feel how it feels
do you wanna know know that it doesn't
hurt me
do you want to hear about the deal I'm
making
my response going forward it's not over
explaining myself
it's not pleading it's um it's not
expecting kindness from someone who has
no kindness to give
my response is in the next joyous video
that I make
that's my response
[Music]
can we pause there
I'm gonna say something that might make
people feel a little bit uncomfortable
um
hard to maintain a relationship with
God and I don't think that he made a
mistake with me
um and that maybe one day I will
actually be grateful for being trans
that this isn't some curse but it's just
a different path to the same destination
be running up that road
be running up
you'll be running up that building
[Music]
I'm sorry to cut that off because it's
really quite powerful
um powerful for a few reasons one it
proves that somebody can hit all the
notes and still sound terrible and also
it proves all of the points that we have
been trying to make about this man after
all our entire criticism of Mulvaney is
is that he is not a woman but rather a
performer wearing Womanhood as a costume
his idea of woman is what he learned
from Disney cartoons and how exactly
does he respond to that charge well
by dressing up as a Disney princess
and dancing around on stage and
delivering a tearful monologue while
singing exactly as a Disney princess
would a monologue that by his own
admission he has been rehearsing for a
week as part of a performance he had
planned six months ago so his tears are
then about as authentic as everything
else about him which is to say they are
utterly contrived and staged just more
emotional manipulation meant to shut
down valid criticism I mean imagine a
man you know in black face
singing a self-pitying song about how
his heart breaks whenever someone tells
him that his costume is offensive to
black people that there is no difference
here
Mulvaney pretends that he doesn't
understand the criticism
that's because the trans agenda runs
exclusively on falsehoods bad faith and
emotional blackmail and Mulvaney
exemplifies all three he puts on a
cartoonish performance of Womanhood that
is as degrading and absurd as possible
he monetizes the performance he
amplifies it through every platform
available and then when the criticism
rightly comes his wife he acts like he's
just some random person trying to live
his private life and peace
speaking of his critics he says that he
doesn't know what our goals are now
I think he does but for the moment I'll
allow for the possibility that he's as
stupid and oblivious as he wants us to
think he is and so I will explain
our goal is to defend reality and it
really is not any more complicated than
that
and here's one reality
no real woman
will ever get a red carpet Extravaganza
at the Rockefeller Center to
congratulate her for simply existing
okay no real woman is going to get that
for actually being a woman for a year
that's the kind of spectacle only
reserved for Dylan Mulvaney a privilege
enjoyed by him and people like him
why is that a problem well for a lot of
reasons but I can illustrate uh one of
the reasons with uh maybe a brief story
so I think about
when our most recent set of twins were
born uh and uh and I I'll never forget
the moment of course two months ago
standing in the delivery room first baby
born successfully no problems but then
the situation turns dire with the second
the doctor unable to safely deliver
because of a prolapse umbilical cord has
to make a split second decision to
perform an emergency C-section uh it's
uh there's a lot of blood I'd never been
in the room for any kind of operation
before I don't know exactly what I was
expecting but I was expecting all that
the blood and um and then there was my
wife you know laying there calm but
shivering at several points on the verge
of passing out the only thing I could do
was hold her hand and tell her the
babies are okay and everything's gonna
be fine and I did tell her that even
though for a period of several minutes I
wasn't sure if it was actually true but
everything was fine in the end and uh my
wife has now taken on the task of caring
for these two infants along with four
other children with Incredible Grace and
joy
and I'm not surprised to see her meet
the challenge that way she's a
remarkable woman I've always known
that's why I married her
and yet
there will never be an event at the
Rockefeller Center to celebrate my
wife's Womanhood okay she's not gonna
have any adoring crowds flocking to bask
in her presence and applaud her and fawn
over her for being a woman
she knows more about being a woman than
Dylan Mulvaney will ever know or could
ever know she's experienced Womanhood at
the deepest level she she Bears its
scars literally she carries its burdens
she knows it's blessing she's a wife a
mother a daughter a sister she's all the
things that Mulvaney and his ilk have
never been and can never understand
and yet he is put on the stage with a
spotlight and the corporate sponsorships
he is celebrated for being what he isn't
it's like giving the Medal of Honor to
some dude who played Call of Duty in his
basement
now it's not that my wife would want all
of this Fanfare she's not a raging
narcissist like Dylan Mulvaney the point
is simply that by elevating and
celebrating these fake cartoon faux
women
our society has emptied Womanhood of
everything that's truly beautiful and
meaningful and important about it
and if there's any Solace to women they
aren't alone in this boat far from it
the same has happened with manhood uh
the same has happened with with
everything
all that is good and true is hollowed
out
and made artificial and absurd and ugly
you know it's funny that one of Dylan's
cohorts on stage there says that we his
critics
uh want to keep them in The Matrix
now as always the truth is exactly the
other way around
gender ideology is the Matrix
well you just saw there on the screen
that's the Matrix
it's you know I'm sad to say it's not
nearly as cool as the movie version
but that's our version of The Matrix
what you just saw it is a fake alternate
universe it is an artificial projection
meant to obscure reality
and we are urged to play along so as not
to ruin the illusion
but we some of us anyway are tired of
illusions
we are tired of the artificial
we are tired of imitations
we want reality
if we're going to celebrate Womanhood
then we're going to celebrate the real
thing
and that is not you doing
and it never will be
now let's get to our five headlines
you know with everything going on in the
world right now you could really use a
good night's sleep that's why you need
to check out Helix mattress I've had my
Helix for years now and I absolutely
love it a mattress should never be a one
size fits-all solution because why
should you have to compromise on comfort
that makes no sense to do that Helix has
a sleep quiz that matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you because you don't want
to buy a mattress that was made for
somebody else you got to go to
helixsleep.com Walsh take their two
minute sleep quiz and you can find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type your mattress will come right to
your door for free Helix has a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for a
hundred nights risk-free believe it pick
it up for you if you don't love it but
you will I know that I did for a limited
time Helix is giving you a 20 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners take advantage of this
amazing offer at helixsleep.com Walsh
with Helix better sleep starts now
all right we'll begin uh with this from
it's actually from last week it's a
report by KSTP in Minnesota it says
Minnesota Governor Tim Walls uh signed
an executive order on Wednesday aimed at
protecting the rights of Minnesota's
lgbtq plus community and access to
gender affirming Health Care lieutenant
governor Peggy Flanagan joined walls for
the signing ceremony of the Capitol
shortly before 11 A.M it comes as a few
states around the country consider
restricting drag shows Tennessee's
governor recently banned public drag
performances labeling them as adult
Cabaret several other States including
Idaho North Dakota Montana and Oklahoma
are considering similar Bans wall said
that the the order of direct State
officials to work with Health Care
officials to ensure access to gender
affirming care is available to everyone
and also made clear that state won't
cooperate with any other seeking to
restrict the rights of or punish anyone
in the lgbtq plus community in other
words this is this is the bill that
we've talked about on the show The
Sanctuary essentially Sanctuary State
build turning Minnesota to Sanctuary
state for uh Kyle child castration
mutilation
and so abusive parents can bring their
kid to Minnesota to uh to be abused in
this way and Minnesota is saying we're
not going to cooperate with any of the
the states that have made this
this kind of thing illegal so that was
the bill but I want you to listen to
what the lieutenant governor had to say
at the signing ceremony as she was um
you know talking about the importance of
being able to castrate mutilated
children here's what she said
because let's be clear
this is life affirming and life-saving
health care
when our children tell us who they are
it is our job as grown-ups to listen and
to believe them
that's what it means to be a good parent
it's what it means to be a good parent
is to listen to and believe whatever our
children say
now we hear this we hear this kind of
thing so often from these people and uh
but it still manages to be shockingly
ridiculous every time we see it you know
every time we hear it because it is
the job of a parent is so often
to do exactly the opposite of that
to to uh
in fact that is always the job oh
there's always the job of the parent to
not automatically believe whatever your
kid says or go along with whatever they
want to do
now there could be times when your kid
says something that you should believe
okay that happens plenty of times uh or
there can be like plenty of occasions
where a child wants to do something and
you say yes that's a good idea let's do
that
but
that should never be your automatic
reflexive
stance
um and least of all should you believe
it or go along with it just because they
said it
all right there is I I think there's a
there's a place and some people in you
know with with the way uh modern
parenting strategies don't agree with
this but I would still say because I'm
somewhat old-fashioned well maybe not
somewhat
that there's definitely a place as a
parent
for the uh Because I Said So reasoning
to your child
where you say we're going to do
something you say something and they
don't agree that they ask why and and
your your response was because I said so
and because because now if your child is
asking questions in a in a sincere way
and they're really trying to understand
then you should try to explain it to
them but sometimes a child can can go
down the Y Rabbit Hole or object and
it's just uh it's just a way of being
defined and so then you want to train
the child to understand that they need
to respect you and your Authority and
even if they don't understand why they
have to do something
um they still shouldn't do it okay if
the child doesn't quite understand why
they shouldn't run into the middle of
the street uh it doesn't matter don't
run to the street because I said so
so
that's parent to child because I said so
and yeah these days that as I said many
people would say well that's no that's
that's authoritarian you can't parent
that way because I said so is never the
appropriate response
and yet they want it to go the other way
essentially they think that should be a
valid uh response from the child to the
parent
hey Mom and Dad we're gonna do this this
is how I'm gonna live my life uh well
why do you because I said so it's
because I said so and and that means we
you have to go along with it
no you your job you are because because
the child doesn't have the capacity for
discernment
certainly not a a fully developed
capacity then it is your job to be that
you know you are kind of pinch-hitting
uh so often as the person who's able to
engage in discernment
um so you have to you have to lend him
your discernment powers
which means you're saying no a lot to a
child
that's the way it has to go
so this is
it it it's not just completely
ridiculous when it comes to this
particular topic
although it is especially ridiculous and
harmful there when it comes to the topic
of gender ideology
but uh across the board it makes no
sense at all
a similar uh similar topic here Joe
Biden this week spoke out against
states that are Banning child castration
sterilization and he had his own
reasoning that he offered listen to this
transgender kids is a really harder day
thing what's going on in Florida
is as my mother would say close to
sinful I mean it's just terrible what
they're doing it's not like you know a
kid wakes up one morning and says you
know
I decided I want to become a man or I
want to become a woman or I want to
change I mean what what what are they
thinking about here
they're human beings they love they have
feelings they have inclinations that are
I mean it just to me is
I don't know it's cruel and the way we
do it is we make sure we pass
legislation like we passed on same-sex
marriage you mess with that you're
breaking the law and you're going to be
held accountable
so what he's what he's actually saying
here is uh if we're to skip right over
the sinful part which really we can't we
can't skip over that I mean this is
you know yet again
the the left
going right to the moral argument
and for so long on the right and
conservatives they've told themselves
that uh we can't you know you don't want
to make the moral argument moral
arguments not persuasive uh people don't
we don't want to legislate morality we
don't want to be accused of that so
we're always going to make the Practical
argument or the economic argument the
financial argument
uh we're gonna make an argument rooted
in rights and Liberties which is still a
moral argument by the way oh I mean all
these are even the financial argument
it's an economic Arts it's always in the
end a moral argument
but this is what the conservatives have
been uh convinced of and for years have
gone along with it gotta make we gotta
make we got to make an argument that
seems practical
meanwhile on the left they go right for
the moral argument every single time
and a religious argument too
they'll tell us not to do it
so if we say something you're trying to
shove your religion down our throat
and so often conservatives have have
been persuaded by this kind of
manipulation
but then what do you hear from Biden
it's sinful
it is a sin and what is he saying it is
a sin to not
castrate a child
to not do that would be a sin
and since he brought it up I mean he's
bringing sin into the conversation uh
I'd love to hear him flesh that out some
more where are you getting that
biblically
please point to the point give me a
chapter and verse here of
um you know the the the the the part of
of scripture
that leads you to believe that we are
not only is it okay to castrate a child
but we're actually morally obligated to
sterilize castrate mutilate children
um
so he says it's sinful and for that
reason he says it's sinful and for that
reason
um
what he's advocating now is the federal
government to get involved and uh and
step in
and stop these States from passing these
laws
that's the level that they're they're
playing they're going to take their
moral argument and they're going to
translate that directly into legal
action
and why are they going to do it
you know why does he want the federal
government to step in and say to
Tennessee for example you're not allowed
to pass a law like that
why well because it's it's the right
thing to do they say
so they go right to the more argument
and we we in effect surrender that
ground to them which we absolutely
shouldn't do
and our response is why shouldn't you be
doing these things to Children Well to
begin with it's it's wrong it is morally
wrong uh and it is grounded in falsehood
this is also funny from Joe Biden um an
alleged letter from a child though based
on the handwriting and spelling it looks
like something could have easily written
to himself
but we can put the Tweet up on the uh on
the screen so this is why he tweeted out
first the letters a screenshot of the
letter
it says Dear President Biden I just
wanted to tell something not fair to
ladies men are getting more money than
girls I think you should fix this since
you're the president
even I'm a child and I think that we
should do something from Charlotte
and then Biden responds Charlotte I
couldn't agree more women lose thousands
of dollars each year and hundreds of
thousands over a lifetime because of
gender and racial wage gaps I'm
committed to building an economy where
my daughters have the same rights and
opportunities as my sons
uh it's always interesting to me when
they use children to make their points
and they think that that of course the
reason they do is I think it makes it
more powerful you see even a child
even a even a child can understand that
why this isn't isn't right there's a
there's a gender wage even a child can
understand that
no it's not even a child
it's that
um of course a child
will will have this view of it if you
say it to a child
you know uh
men men go out and work and they're
women who go out and work and if you add
up all the money that men make and women
make uh men make a little bit more
now if you say that to a child in in
their in their childlike mind they're
going to just assume that this must be
you know evidence that there's some sort
of plot to stop women from from earning
more they're not going to ask questions
like well are we comparing uh people who
work in the same industry so we are we
comparing men in one industry with women
in the same industry are we factoring in
things like hours worked experience
level uh skill qualifications
um all of that kind of thing
are are we are we taking into account
things like men are more willing to uh
move for a job that women are men are
more willing to take on extra hours that
women are men are much more likely to do
dangerous jobs and the dangerous jobs
very often will pay more I mean working
on an oil rig for example is a
well-paying gig and it's also dangerous
a child's not going to ask any of those
questions okay so this so Charlotte
who's how overall she is let's assume
she's seven or eight years old or
something
she's not gonna ask that because she's a
kid
and so when you tell her about the quote
wage Gap that's all she's gonna think is
okay well there must be
there must be some evil plan out there
to stop girls from making more
um but it's adults who are supposed to
be able to understand that there are a
lot of other factors to take into
account here
and you can't just do a generalized
comparison between all women in the
workplace place and all men that doesn't
make any sense to do that
so all he's really proving
is that
um
the the leftist view of the so-called
gender wage Gap is childish
it's the kind of thing that resonates
with a small child
and when you become older and you
understand a little bit more about how
the world works and you also understand
how statistics work uh that's when you
can understand this is all nonsense
all right
here's a
article from The Daily Mail says Netflix
has quietly canceled a woke animated
kids show which features a bison who
comes out as non-binary to its
grandmother
Ridley Jones released its Fifth and
final season last week which was not
given any promotion according to
according to the show's Creator Chris
knee the two-time kids screen Award
winner and Emmy nominee series received
harsh criticism online following the
release of episode 8 of season 5 called
herd day which centers around a bison
called Fred who comes out as non-binary
to their grandmother who's voiced by
Sydney Lopper
some viewers blasted the show on Twitter
claiming Fred's non-binary identity was
slipped into the show's narrative
so okay so the series is called Ridley
Jones
about a bison I've never even heard of
this show before
one viewer asked quote do your kids
watch Ridley Jones it features a female
bison who identifies as neither male nor
female and wants to be referred to as
they them pronouns quietly slipped in
there drip drip drip what a message to
send to young girls in particular
the Creator who's a lesbian mom
addressed the cancellation in a tweet
last Wednesday says doesn't surprise me
that Netflix has quietly dumped the
first preschool show that has a
non-binary character coming out I
realize in this day and age dumped means
many things just zero promotion of the
episode
first of all I'm pretty sure this is not
unfortunately I wish I could say that
this was the first preschool show that
has a non-binary character I'm pretty
sure that's not the case I mean they've
got you know they're they're doing uh
Pride parades and uh drag queens in
Blues Clues now so this is ground that
has been shred before but I think we
have the clip from the show let's watch
that
that's because I'm non-binary and Fred
is the name that fits me best and I also
use they and them because calling me a
she or a he doesn't feel right to me I'm
sorry I used the wrong name and few
names
well yes exactly as we exactly as we
were told a uh
a non-binary bison in the kids show
and it is uh it's it is at least
encouraging
that this show is a total flop and now
it's being quiet and of course Netflix
isn't going to make a big scene about it
but um
it's a flop people aren't interested
people don't want this and now they have
to cancel the show that is that is
encouraging
because as much as uh you know we have a
problem with woke parents who want to uh
indoctrinate their kids into this what
we see is that still the vast majority
of parents do not want this they're not
interested in it
and that includes plenty of parents who
otherwise might be mistakenly okay with
some of this kind of stuff
there are probably still and this this
is uh changing as the world crowd
becomes ever more radicalized by the day
but there are still plenty of parents
who would say something like well uh you
know non-binary I support that
you know they would legitimize the idea
being non-binary but they still
they're not going to sit their kid down
to watch a show with that stuff in it
and then there's also a group of parents
who who would support that and might
even say that they would sit their kids
down to watch something like this but
then in reality they're not going to
um so that's the positive anyway
this is from the blaze it says a
transgender UK doctor known for being a
fatness Advocate expressed outrage that
thin people were being celebrated for
the whale movie at the Oscar awards
ceremony on Sunday the movie about a man
dealing with his obesity problem and
directed by Darren Aronofsky garnered
Oscar awards for best makeup and hair
styling and for best actor Dr Asher
Laramie who also identifies as
non-binary of course Unleashed a furious
tirade on Twitter over the fat phobic
incident
quote once again just a reminder that
the whale was written by directed by and
produced by four thin white rich
able-bodied cisgender men oh and check
it out check out it's fat star who was
celebrated and honored at the Oscars
last night what an effing joke
Laramie added quote are we able to wrap
our heads around this one yet folks
someone won an Oscar for making Brendan
Fraser a currently straight sized man
it went straight sized man
is that what we're referring to someone
someone who's not you know overly obese
is straight sized
anyway someone won an Oscar for making
Brendan Fraser a currently straight
sized man look fat no one else finds
this disturbing
well no no one else finds this
disturbing because it's uh it's acting
and there's all and yet again there's
this uh you know on one hand
we live in a culture that is extremely
paranoid about appropriation
and and that's what this is It's
considered appropriation
and at the exact same time you have what
we talked about in the opening monologue
with Dylan Mulvaney
which is an example of actual
appropriation is what is appropriation
you know
in in a in a movie
it's like we're not supposed to actually
believe that Brendan Fraser is a 600
pound man it's a it's a film he is he is
openly portraying a character no one's
pretending otherwise he's not
identifying as this character he's just
he's telling a story
and to be able to we've talked about
this before but it you know this is
supposed to be I would think
the real art of acting and if there's
any anything honorable about the
profession it if there is anything it
would be this that uh you have to have
in order to to inhabit
um a character that is not you and to be
able to do it persuasively you have to
have some kind of empathy you know and
that's what makes I watch the movie
that's what makes it a a compelling
performance is that even though Brendan
Frazier is not a 600 pound man uh who's
living through the last what's going to
end up being the last week of his life
spoiler alert
um you still while you're watching the
story you believe it
in order for him to make you believe
that he has to kind of understand this
character in a way so that's a it's a
it's a it is an empathetic performance
and almost any good performance is
but it's also not appropriation because
again it is it is it is uh
everyone understands that it is a
performance he's not taking ownership of
this and saying oh I now identify as a
600 pound man
on the other hand you have something
like Dylan Mulvaney who's actually
trying to take yes it's a performance
but he's trying to take ownership of the
performance and say this is really me
this is who I am
so that's appropriation but we have it
exactly flipped around
meanwhile uh Jamie Lee Curtis won an
Oscar for her role in uh the film
everything everywhere all at once which
uh I did watch that one well I watched
two-thirds of it and I couldn't get
through the rest
and I I don't often
you know alternative I'll frequently
turn a movie off in the first five
minutes because it's not worth my time I
got two thirds of the way through I
almost always finish because you figure
well I've made it this far I've already
wasted my time I might as well see how
it all ends but this film was so
obnoxious and pointless that I couldn't
I couldn't do it anymore and I turned it
off
but she won the Oscar anyway for a small
role and here she is talking about her
Oscar trophy
oh look at this here
have we named her who
my daughter Ruby I'm I'm having them be
a they them oh
um I'm I'm gonna just call them them
they them and um they are doing great
and uh they're settling in
um and um I couldn't I mean I just
in my life I never saw it in a million
years that I would have this couple days
and I'm I'm very very moved by the whole
thing
oh it's powerful
her Oscar trophy is a they them you know
I saw someone I don't know I confess I
don't know anything at all about Jamie
Lee Curtis's
um uh you know her her personal life and
and her biographical details but I saw
someone
on Twitter mentioned this that she has I
guess two kids
and one of them is uh identifies as a I
think a non-binary trans furry or
something and is a YouTuber
um furry demon I I think
and that's Ruby
and then Jamie Lee Curtis also has a a
daughter a real daughter who's like a
normal person and is a teacher or
something and works with uh works with
kids and and people with uh with
disabilities
and yet
she spends most of her time talking
about the transferee
you know YouTuber
that's who she apparently is the most
proud of
tells you everything you need to know
about Hollywood I suppose let's get to
the comment section
man it's required that you grow a beard
hey we're the sweet baby gang
are you tired of making doctor's
appointments waiting in long lines and
feeling embarrassed to discuss sensitive
health concerns with Rex MD you don't
have to Rex MD understands that no one
likes to go to the doctor's office
that's why they've created a safe online
platform for men to discreetly consult
consult with licensed Physicians and get
personalized treatment plans Rex MD
makes it easy and inexpensive to get
generic and branded Viagra or Cialis
online there's no waiting rooms there's
no embarrassing trips to the doctor
there's no insurance there's no co-pays
it's all upside with just a few clicks
of a button you can talk to a medical
professional create a personalized plan
and get the product shipped straight to
your door Rex MD doesn't just offer ED
medication they also offer medications
that help with hair growth pain relief
sleep aid unlike other brands Rex MD is
FDA approved clinically tested and a U.S
licensed Pharmacy Rex MD has already
helped over 300 000 guys gain confidence
quickly and conveniently they're here to
help you to take advantage of their best
deal yet at rexmd.com Walsh and Save 90
off by paying only two dollars per
dosage that's rexmd.com walls for up to
90 off go to rexmd.com for more details
and safety information
I have to briefly mention this because
uh my wife though being a great woman as
mentioned earlier also almost got
herself canceled today she almost made
it into the daily cancellation it's been
a little while since she's been there
and uh she she
almost earned another trip
so here's what she did
she she went out and I can't don't ask
me to explain this because I can't but
she went out and bought harmonicas
harmonicas for all of our kids
except the two babies so she didn't get
harmonicas for the infants at least for
the four kids she got harmonicas again
can't explain why
can't even theorize
but she got them all harmonicas and so
this is what my house sounded like all
weekend
[Music]
oh
you can hear my six-year-old silence
everyone for a moment so that they can
hear his harmonica solo and that was my
that was my life all weekend it was just
that I kept confiscating the harmonicas
and but then they would end up back in
circulation again and uh I you know I I
would I took them out to eat on Saturday
at a restaurant two of them pulled out
their harmonicas at the at the
restaurant and started playing them my
daughter started playing harmonica in
the car I almost drove into a tree and
the thing is I this is what makes it I
like the harmonica at least I used to
and so we're driving in the car and all
the songs I put on
they're on my Spotify playlist all of
them have have harmonicas in them
because prior to this I thought
that there's no bad way to play
harmonica and harmonica improves every
song
and uh so I put you know I'm just
listening to music the kids are in the
car and my my daughter pulls all the
harmonica starts playing along to the
music
debunking my theory about a harmonica
making everything sound better it was
like being followed around by a by a
like a Blues Traveler cover band all
weekend
the good news now is that they've all
been lost so that's you know you buy
your kids a noisy toy and within uh
three three four days they're all gone
uh and when I say lost I mean quote
unquote they've been lost I don't know
what happened to them
William Baker says I was a Nashville and
saw a bachelorette party with their cash
app handle displayed I did the fair and
Equitable thing and requested five
dollars from them they still have not
paid uh I think that's a great response
that's what people need to start doing
this is a big thing in Nashville I don't
know I've complained before about this I
don't know how common it is
I do a fair amount of traveling I don't
see it as much in other cities but
in particular because Nashville is
unfortunately the bachelorette party
capital of the of the world uh we get a
lot of this of you know women driving
around in their cars with their cash app
or venmo or whatever proudly displayed
on their windshield
panhandling and these are off like it's
it's okay
if you're a woman you can't you came
with all your friends to Nashville for a
bachelorette party that already tells me
you might not be rich
but you're not impoverished if you've
got the money to go to another city for
a for a to party all weekend then uh
you're not uh you're not exactly a
person in need
and yet they there's no compunction
about
essentially you put it on your
windshield then every single person who
happens to be behind you in traffic
you're asking them for money
um no shame at all
Jared says I had the opposite problem as
Kaepernick I asked my parents for a rat
tail and they were 100 on board now I
have pictures of myself with a rat tail
hairstyle and a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle sweater well that was just the
90s for you but that is uh it just goes
to show it's like we talked about the
during the headlines you know you can't
you cannot say yes to everything your
kids want
and in the 90s for some reason
there were a lot of parents who said yes
to the rat tail and I even at the time
I never quite understood that I mean
it's
work you call the hairstyle a rat tail
it doesn't even sound appealing based on
the based on the name
and yet there are many parents and now
their their children have to live with
those uh photos in circulation for the
rest of their lives
um
Kitty gaming tombs toon says I'd like to
see Matt Walsh debate Dylan Mulvaney
that'll be a fun video idea well I would
that would certainly never happen
uh none of these people are going to put
themselves in a position
intentionally put themselves in a
position of being uh of being
scrutinized I think that's one thing
that we've
that we've learned Becca says I'll be
honest up until recently I was very
left-wing very liberal I heard all the
nasty things said about Matt Walsh
should I believe them but to make a long
story short after digging around for
myself and actually watching your
content I'm really really really
starting to question my political
opinions I've always thought the gender
ideology stuff was kind of strange but I
figured it was probably some kind of
internalized insert insert buzzword
phobia now I'm thinking that my first
reaction was right it is strange and
worse than that it's wrong and dangerous
that has led me to questioning a lot of
stuff and it's also led to me beginning
to really love your videos and all that
you're doing Mr Walsh keep it up because
you're changing people and doing good
well Becca I appreciate that
um although I'm I'm
sorry I have to be the one to tell you
this but you don't exist Becca I don't
know if you realize that but you don't
exist at least I've been told I've been
reliably informed that people like you
don't exist that would be someone on the
left
who can be persuaded by
simple sometimes blunt arguments that
are presented without you know a lot of
uh without going out of the way to make
them make it you know make it gentle and
give a soft Landing now that's what I'm
told
like the way that I approach things it
could never be persuasive to Someone
Like You
so either what I'm being told is wrong
or you don't exist I don't know
we'll have to think about that
what if I told you there's one book that
has done more for literacy than any
other book it's shaped literature art
culture government countless lives I'm
of course referring to uh Johnny The
Walrus now I'm referring to the Bible
actually Johnny Lawrence is second place
you know who else is uh has uh has had
an influence on that is Jordan Peterson
in addition to his Exodus series Jordan
has a documentary called logos and
literacy where he traces the Bible
through history to show you the impact
it's had on the western world uh here's
the trailer check it out I was very much
struck by how the translation of the
biblical writings jump started the
development of literacy across the
entire world
the pastor's home was the first school
and every morning into a begin with
singing the Christian faith is a singing
religion probably 80 percent of Scripps
memorization today exists only because
of what is sung
is amazing here we have a Gutenberg
Bible printed on the Press of Johan
goodberg science and religion are
opposing forces in the world but
historically that has not been the case
now the book is available to everyone
from Shakespeare to modern education and
medicine and science to to civilization
itself it is the most influential book
in all history and hopefully people can
walk away with at least a sense of that
now you know this is the part where I
normally tell you that logos literacy is
only for daily wire Plus members but
actually we're making it available for
free for everyone at dailywireplus.com
but it's only for a limited time we
don't do this very often so take
advantage of it go watch a logos
illiteracy today at dailywireplus.com
now let's get to our daily cancellation
foreign
last week the daily wire published the
book stolen youth by Carol Markowitz and
Bethany Mandel and the book exposes The
left's Assault on childhood which is
waged largely through indoctrination
campaigns by the media the education
system the entertainment business and of
course the medical industry it's an
important Book on a crucial topic I'd
recommend that you pick up a copy and
give it a read of course the problem
with writing a book is that once it
comes out you have to promote it and
promoting it means you have to do an
ungodly number of interviews where you
answer the same sorts of questions over
and over and over and over again and you
would hope that the repetition would
make you sharper you know you have
better honed answers each time but it
doesn't always work out that way the
excessive exposure to cameras and
microphones can instead lead to minor
flubs and gaffes brain farts to use the
medical term and this wouldn't be a huge
deal except for the fact that we live in
the era of social media where the peanut
gallery is looking for any opportunity
to turn a brief mental lapse into an
entire news cycle
that's what happened this week to one of
the authors of the book Bethany Mandel
when she appeared on a show called
Rising yesterday to promote her book and
she was asked
in the interview to define the word woke
and if you're being asked that question
Mandel momentarily fumbled over the
answer and that was all the left-wing
mob needed her name was soon trending
Nationwide thousands of people jumping
on the dog pile there were articles
published in mainstream media Outlets
like the Washington Post and the
independent uh the left ruthlessly
mocked her for not having a pithy
definition of woke ready to go claiming
that this lapse somehow proves that the
conservative critique of wokeness is
illegitimate The Washington Post
headline summarizes this line of
thinking it said quote a viral moment
reinforces the hollowness of woke as an
attack
meanwhile left us on social media
claimed that the viral moment is evident
somehow that the term woke is a bigoted
term a guy named Torre posted quote at
this point woke is a slur the way the
right uses it is an undercover way of
saying those people or non-white people
it's a polite way of saying the n-word
but in this case the n-word includes
blacks lgbtq folks and other
marginalized groups
well of course you know obviously woke
is a racial slur it's a term
conservatives used after all which means
that it's racist automatically
whatever else we could say about it we
must begin by calling it racist and also
End by calling it racist because of
course everything is racist
as for the clip that has provoked all of
this reaction
um let's just watch that and then we'll
discuss here it is
kind of Americans consider themselves
very liberal and probably fewer of them
consider themselves to be woke and so
you know when when
would you mind the finding well because
it's come up a couple times I just want
to make sure we're on the same page
so I mean woke is sort of the idea that
um
I
this is going to be one of those moments
that goes viral I mean woke is something
that's very hard to Define and we've
spent an entire chapter defining it
it is sort of the understanding that we
need to re totally reimagine and re
reduce Society in order to create
hierarchies of Oppression
um
sorry I it's hard to explain in a 15
second sound bite yeah
okay so two points here first if I was
asked to Define woke I would say that
it's a cult or a secular religion which
uh teaches that Society is systemically
oppressive towards certain supposedly
marginalized groups the cult believes
that our institutions were built
expressly with the purpose of oppressing
these groups and the only way to combat
the oppression is to tear down the
institutions and restructure them
according to the doctrines of the cult
nothing can exist for its own sake in
when it comes to Wilderness no
institution can have any purpose above
or beyond the enforcement of those
doctrines
the ultimate goal according to the cult
is equity and Equity simply means that
the imagined oppression of their favored
groups has been counteracted by policies
that artificially Elevate those same
groups
and of course in the woke religion the
Satan figure is the heterosexual white
male and each member of this group
inherits the collective guilt of the
oppressor
in fact you could probably Define the
term woke this way too a woke person is
anyone who thinks that heterosexual
white males are the villains of History
if they hold that belief then it's
almost always certain that the rest of
it will will come with it now if some
conservatives
struggle maybe to define the term woke
it's only because they're being too
generous you know there are some on the
right who want to see the woke left as
distinct from the left generally they
seek to Define wokeness in a way that
lets what they consider to be the
average leftist off the hook but there's
no way to do that
waltness is just another term for
leftism you can also Define it that way
what's a woke person a leftist that's
that's that's what we're talking about
there is no daylight between like the
the stereotypical blue-haired woke
Tick-Tock they them and uh and the most
mainstream Democrat political figure
okay there's no daylight ideologically
between these two they are identical
ideological
the term woke only becomes complicated
and hard to Define when you're trying to
find some way to differentiate
mainstream leftism from walkness
but they can't be differentiated
woke is a is another word for leftist
which is why I personally don't use the
term woke very often because leftist
suffice is just fine
second point
um leftists you know the wolf crowd
whatever you want to call them they are
certainly not in a position to make fun
of anyone else for struggling to define
a word
if there's another defining feature of
wokeness is that it's it creates a world
governed from top to bottom by double
standards and here we find yet another
one
these people can't objectively define
any of the terms they use and yet they
point and laugh at someone else for
fumbling over a definition
most infamously of course they can't
Define the word woman but the difference
between woman and woke is that the
latter is an ideology which means that
it actually is a human construct it
actually is uh somewhat fluid and and
changing it really does exist on a
spectrum of sorts
you know that's ideologies really do
exist on a spectrum
there are bits of it many bits in fact
that are murky and vague
this means that it's not terribly
shocking or hilarious when a person
fails to come up with a pithy definition
on the spot I can guarantee that none of
these leftists making fun of Bethany
Mandel would would perform any better if
we ask them to Define fascism on the
spot
and although they throw the term fascism
around all over the place I wouldn't
necessarily blame them for not having a
one sentence definition ready to go
because ideologies are a bit more
complicated than that
and a bit more
um abstract and sometimes ambiguous a
woman on the other hand is not an
ideology woman is an objective
biological reality human beings didn't
invent Womanhood the way that we invent
ideologies it's not an idea it's not a
political concept woman has a basic one
sentence definition adult human female
that every rational person should know
and should be able to cite whenever
asked
and yet the left the woke mob
cannot provide this definition
Mandel briefly struggled to Define an
idea that's what you're saying how do
you define this idea
well these people struggle to Define
ideas but they also struggle to find
literally everything else including the
fundamental biological realities of
nature
you know it's it's one thing to put an
ideological label on someone else and
then briefly struggle to Define that
label
it's another thing entirely to label
yourself something like saying I
identify as a woman and then being
completely unable to Define what you
labeled yourself
okay because that's that's the gotcha
moment here right there's a the the left
they say well you're you you call all
these people woke and then we ask you
what you mean by woke and you can't tell
us
well no we can tell you it just it might
take more than one sentence but we can
tell you meanwhile you're calling
yourself something that you can't then
explain how much more ridiculous is that
it's not just a minor Gaff or a gotcha
moment rather it reveals the fundamental
incoherence of your entire world view
but that again is another feature of
wokeness
perhaps it's the finding feature before
anything else it is an ideology that
contradicts and negates itself at every
turn an ideology that asserts things as
true and yet denies the truth exists it
is an ideology of confusion most of all
maybe that's how we would define it
wokeness is confusion made into an
ideology I think that works too
and that is why Bethany Mandel is not
canceled instead her woke counselors are
today canceled
and I'll do it for the show today as we
uh move over to the members block if you
want to join us for that you can become
a member and use code walls to check out
for two months free on all annual plans
hope to see you there if not talk to you
tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]